exhausted but relieved their nightmare
is at an end
last week these residents were pulled
from their beds in the middle of the
night after two people living floors
apart tested positive for covert 19 it
sparked fears the virus could be
traveling through the pipes gripping
Hong Kong with a collective dread that
it was about to watch history repeat
itself this is a Moy Gardens in 2003 it
became synonymous with tragedy 42
residents lost their lives to the SARS
epidemic hundreds more were infected
defective pipes had been carrying the
virus directly into people's homes
the horrible garden has become the pole
city no people are there to come home to
the other garden I feel so so sad and so
powerless even those after seven years
the image are still be coming to Hawaii
tomorrow the horror of what happened
here is still seared in people's minds
many still haunted by the scale of the
tragedy and it's that which is now
fueling fears today mr. Yip says lessons
have been learned and additional hygiene
measures introduced but that's done
little for calm nerves with masks and
hand sanitizer both in short supply
toilet rolls now the latest target of
panic shoppers concerns so great one
online rumor of a shortage was all it
took to empty the shelves is actually
justified how would they know who
wouldn't I can be talking with a friend
who appears to be opportunity a
cinematic and then I may be infected and
I may die
professor Lai treated SARS victims he
sees echoes of past mistakes and thinks
more must be done to prevent another
devastating outbreak he is repeating
yourself already I think at least at
least if the Hong Kong authorities to
encourage everyone every single one to
wear masks and also supply adequate
equipments for the method we start to
actually protect himself
for sales victims this outbreak is
particularly painful
Alex lamb leads a network of survivors
while they're bracing for the worst he
says SARS is proof that Hong Kong can
come back from the brink back in 2003 we
spent four to five months time - to
fight against the disease this time we
may have a longer time to fight and we
should not be led by the fear inside us
even those we have the past experience
that we should be telling everyone here
we are we came across the most difficult
time in life but we are standing here
back at home a house authorities have
given residents the all clear but
caution here was born from experience
given Hong Kong's past the spread of
fear can be as challenging to contain as
the virus itself another doctor in China
has died after contracting the new
corona virus in Wuhan the epicenter of
the outbreak the doctor's death comes as
health officials in China published
details of a study into 70,000 cases of
the virus the report suggests that the
number of new infections is falling so
far the virus has killed just over 2
percent of those infected with older
people and those with existing
conditions more likely to die but
Beijing warns that could change when
people start returning to daily life for
more let's get to our correspondent
Mateus Bolinger who is standing by in
Beijing so Mateus according to this
study the number of new infections is
declining does this mean that the worst
is over report indeed strikes an
optimistic tone saying that the number
of new infections is not rising at the
same pace as it was but if we look at
the data more closely the data is up to
the 11th of February now two days after
this state we had a massive increase
in new infections that was caused by a
change in counting by including probable
cases that have not yet been confirmed
into the statistics that day the number
rose by 15,000 in Hubei Province and
then the next day again 5,000 part of
these probable cases are included in
this study but not all of them so all of
this has to be taken with caution what
is true is that we don't see this
pattern of increase in other provinces
outside of who pay but it's still too
early to make a prediction Matias who's
been most impacted by the virus
impacted by the virus are mostly people
over thirty thirty to seventy nine
adults we have some scholars have
already remarked that this remarkable
finding that few children seem to be
affected and for the death fatalities we
can say that mostly elderly people with
most fatalities proportionately most
fatalities in the age group above 70 and
above sixty this is not a surprise this
is what doctors have been saying before
and of course by those who are affected
by infections the number of medical
workers is quite remarkable 3,000
medical workers infected or suspected of
infection so far you mentioned some
numbers there how does this outbreak
compare with previous virus outbreaks
like stars for example well I think the
main difference to sauce and MERS that
is another similar virus is that it
spreads much faster is much more
contagious then SARS the death toll are
the number at a fatality rate is lower
therefore so it is spreading faster but
it is less less deadly than service
Matthias bowling guard joining us from
Beijing thank you